i love the music video almost maybe that
co-stars hannah brown
from the bachelor and the bachelorette
[Music]
what was it like working with hannah
when we started talking about the video
hannah's name name just popped into my
head and i was like guys what if i reach
out to hannah brown
see if she would want to be a part of it
so i reached out to her she
got back to me and said that she would
love to do it and she really is
i mean she's an awesome person like just
sweet as she can be
and she absolutely crushed it but
hannah's not the only famous friend
jordan called on luke bryan
is also featured on the title track by
dirk you came by
[Music]
i say the name luke bryan to you and you
say what luke was
a guy that in college we'd sit around
and
you know have a few beers and and listen
to luke sing so it's like man
to now be here and have him on a song
that means so much to me
is pretty is pretty wild along with
celebrating his new ep jordan is also
excited about his growing
family you have a new baby on the way
how's the family feeling
we're we're excited you know we got my
mom my grandma in town now
uh and and we we are stoked we're trying
to get
in the process of getting eloise ready
for a baby brother so
it's good times over in the davis
household